the Marvel Cinematic Universe has a lot
of extremely powerful characters hey
they're superheroes after all being
super-powered is just part of the whole
deal and fans love to debate just who is
the most powerful of them all is it Thor
the God of Thunder and heir to Odin's
legacy strongest Avenger strongest
Avenger is that the Incredible Hulk
whose strength scales of his nearly
limitless anger is a Hawkeye who can
shoot an arrow real good actually it
turns out that the correct answer is
none of the above because there's one
Marvel legend who goes higher further
and faster than the rest of us mightiest
heroes yes people it's official canon
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige has
confirmed that the most powerful hero in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is Captain
Marvel he's one of the most popular
characters in our comics she's one of
the most powerful characters in the
comics and will be the most powerful
character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
Feige explained that it took a while to
get to the point where the time was
right to finally introduce Captain
Marvel to movie funs Captain Marvel is a
character in our comics and in a
mythology who's got one foot on earth
one foot in a cosmic arena so before she
could be introduced the whole cosmic
side of things had to be explored in
movies like guardians of the galaxy and
Thor Ragnarok now that we've made a
number of movies to take place on earth
and now a number of the cosmic
adventures we thought it was the right
time to finally introduce Captain Marvel
to the world this isn't the first time
he's said it either way back in 2016 and
not long after star brie Larson was cast
as Captain Marvel why he told vulture
the same thing it's very important to us
that all of our heroes to not become
silhouette perfect cutout icons all of
the Marvel characters are flaws to them
and all of them have a deep humanity to
learn with Captain Marvel she is as
powerful a character as we've ever put
in a movie her powers are off the charts
and when she's introduced she will be by
far the strongest character we've ever
had it's important then to
counterbalance that with someone who
feels real she needs to have a humanity
to tap into and brie Larson can do that
fans saw both sides of Captain Marvel
and full display when the film hit
theaters in March 8th leaving no doubt
that Larson's hero is now the strongest
one in the MCU and that has fans
speculating about what that might mean
when she teamed to the surviving members
of
The Avengers for Avengers endgame the
newest trailer for Avengers and game
featured Captain Marvel wearing civilian
clothes and looking a bit older than she
did in a 1995 set standalone movie
hanging around Avengers HQ this sequence
seemed to directly follow the
mid-credits scene in Captain Marvel
which saw her return to Earth and as the
Avengers where Nick Fury was and that's
of course indicated that she had indeed
received the desperate page fury sent
out in the post-credits scene of
Avengers infinity war he wanted some
help fighting off Thanos well looks like
he got his wish of course exactly how
Captain Marvel's presence will affect
the balance of power in the fight
against a nose for mains to be seen but
considering the bearer of the Captain
Marvel name as long been Thanos his arch
enemy in the comics and considering the
fact that Feige has confirmed that Carol
Danvers is the strongest one there is
or we can say is sorry Thanos time's up
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Avengers are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]